don't make me next Wendy Williams in
tears after being asked about her
divorce from Kevin hunter like really
like are you serious
the 55 year old talk-show host was a
guest on Sirius XM's urban view on
Tuesday where she fought back tears
after being asked about how she's
handling the split from her husband of
22 years he changed out there the credit
cards and the bank accounts and
everything changed no my name is Wendy
hunter and that's my son's name and you
can't take away two one
although Wendy was visibly upset by the
question she insists she's doing okay so
who is winning right now happy are you
yeah I you know Karen I am help I'm
happy I'm healthy despite my yes that's
and and I am at peace with the world and
everyone around me
when asked if she'd ever consider a
reconciliation with Kevin is there a
chance and and this is very complicated
with every now is there don't ask
is there a chance now wa girl no don't
ask I know what you're saying
but my family is good and we'll always
be family the talk show host clearly
isn't letting the drama hold her back
she also revealed some fun new projects
she's looking forward to I came out
swinging and I'm waiting I am winning
right now you know and and and it's only
because I'm a thinker I'm a plotter or
planner and I have what futuristic
visions she sure does lifetime announced
on Tuesday that Williams has signed on
to executive produce a biopic about her
life
the project will reveal the highs and
lows
Williams has experienced throughout her
show and will debut along with a
documentary surrounding her life in 2020
I've always only wanted to be me because
it's too hard to fake being somebody
else like and and if there's one thing
that I get delight in is when people say
oh so this one TV girl is the same all
TV girl I am and you might not get me on
my how you doing best at the grocery
store but you know what I give you that
on the show too if I'm not feeling
something so you know I am my own
inspiration
[Music]